hey this is a uh incredible treat I am
sitting here with one of my all-time
Heroes and good friend lucky me Mr Dana
right back at you Dana Carvey Dana
Carvey Conan O'Brien my favorite very
good friend you didn't say your favorite
what hero
favorite if you have a tough steak at a
restaurant and you can't cut through it
you need it in little pieces you are
Hell on Wheels with a stick I am very
good of the steak Knife that's a nice
tasty pieces not favorite comedian not
favorite humorist favorite favorite
human across a desk
great uh you know I am for my money I'm
excited because uh you have a new
Venture uh and and I'm thrilled to be
part of it because uh you have created a
podcast for the Team Coco Network I have
partnered with Team Coco yes and uh for
business partners I love this idea and
you you pitched me this idea once I
think not even thinking necessarily this
would be a show this was something you
were you were you and your sons were
screwing around and having fun making
kind of a very weird funny Twilight Zone
A scripted podcast and you were telling
it to me and I couldn't stop laughing I
really loved it it's really funny and
it's called the weird place the weird
place yes we just love the Twilight Zone
and we had an idea that we took the
Netflix called the creepy box but just
didn't it was you know we do it's either
the weird place but we wanted to bring
back the Twilight Zone we love we loved
it and we'd seen different incarnations
you know I think it's called The Black
Mirror which is kind of a work of Genius
but it's so dark and we wanted we really
romantically wanted to bring it back and
have it be kind of retro it has a
Darkness to it but there's sort of a a
positivity about it so we we decided to
do a rod
a Twilight Zone type show right narrated
by of course the Twilight Zone was was
uh narrated by Robert Sterling the you
are the Rod Sterling the great Rod
Sterling and it'd be like you know I
don't do a red Sterling but imagine a
you know yeah picture if you will yeah a
man alone a pirate ship in the middle of
the Atlantic yeah you know and then we
we put effects on it we uh we wanted it
to sound retro and kind of like because
we only hear Rod Sterling over a
television so we put like a little bit
of a television effect on it so it's
basically it's storytelling I think in a
way conscripted podcast makes everyone
go what you know they don't get it so I
think it's kind of like an audio audio
short films or short television episodes
but Rod is back in this and and the
voice is back the gravitas is back he's
a perfect straight line for comedy well
also uh this is a great you know use of
your talents because you have such a
great visual mind as a comedian in and
you can do all these voices so you
create these stories these bizarre
stories
um and you know just the ones I've heard
uh have been a joy it's out right now by
the way let me point out to you can get
the workplace yeah wherever you get your
podcasts get the weird place uh because
they're available and they're really
funny but what are some of your favorite
episodes so far well I um my son came up
with a an idea of a man touches globe
and it affects the natural world meaning
if a guy yeah a guy has a globe and if
he touches it a giant finger comes out
of the sky yeah in that part of the
world and crushes things yes or if he
flicked the ocean there'd be a tidal
wave that kind of power it's and
um I started thinking about the
character for that and for some reason
because the person who gets it becomes
power mad yes so I thought of the
Invisible Man which I love the 1933
version right where Claude Reigns
actually got nominated for Academy Award
and he's no know he's mostly invisible
right but I love I love his voice and
then he gets the power the power to rule
the power to rule the world you must see
and then he has an ingenue who's very
innocent Dolores he loves him no clot no
you can't and it's uh it's a two-parter
and we have uh just I'm having so much
fun oh I love doing it so much and
riffing these characters out and working
with my sons closely like that and as
you know writing a lot of time is just
in the moment at the table yep it's not
always at a typewriter and then he went
here and there it's just the guy in the
room and Conan to be one of the best
ever at that of just like oh let's go
that way or let's do this or or in this
one called Mario is my dad my son goes
hey should go on the game I think he
should go in the game you know so it's
you going into the game yeah well a
son's dad a talks it like this it makes
sounds like Mario Brothers
I like to get the Coca-Cola
it's very silly but they uh he comes up
with Notions like that so it's really
satisfying to work with them
um I have I sing in one as a character
called Mr Willoughby which is sort of an
archetypal well tell me about Mr
Willoughby Mr Willoughby is someone
who's kind of created from Magic he's a
mystical character in the in the weird
place and in the episode man touches
club and he uh has people come into this
Fantasy Store that can appear and not
appear it's a knick-knack an oddity
store and he sings a little song when
you come in and he makes dreams come
true so he's got like almost a Willy
Wonka quality I did I did sort of an ed
win kind of guy knock off right welcome
to the Oddity and knickknack store would
you like an auditor
and he's the one who has the man get the
globe who goes through this Supernatural
Journey like it's a wonderful life but
this is what I like like uh say uh it's
like a twisted comedy version of Black
Mirror because what you and and Twilight
Zone
um this allows you to riff you know what
what Comedians and comedy writers and
performers all talk about is when we get
in a room we riff yeah which is we go
back and forth and we try and make
things as silly as possible and uh this
is a show that allows you to do that
because there's no idea that can't fit
in this world you know what I mean I
love about it and there's unlimited
characters for me to do or anyone else
to do and I the the way that it happened
for us working with Matt Powers closely
and Adam
Mr Adam sacks uh yes uh that it took us
a while to kind of uh get get up to
speed with it and um because I like to
riff if I come onto a character and then
I'm riffing you know which I I'll build
it and I'll go further with it and I'll
bring it back so that's why I started
doing all the voices initially and we
would we would do it do some effects
listen to it and go ah it's not working
and keep going and evolving it so it was
kind of like like animation like the way
Pixar does it yeah we built it we didn't
just write it at a table and then voice
it I find so we just kept going and
going and going until it felt really
satisfying so yeah I get to do a lot of
very fun characters in the pirate
episode I play a genius from 1738 whose
name is Smarty Wiggins
of course you do based on a friend of my
mother-in-law's from Ireland and he
taught of dogs like this and I have
ideas about this I've invented a new
thing what is it I call it radon
so when I get does anyone know what
talking about they do I mean he's kind
of a genius yeah you know so he figures
out that the it's a submarine that goes
back in time a nuclear submarine meets
up with these Pirates and they're trying
to figure out what the hell is going on
and smarty figures out that the the the
craft they're seeing is a nuclear
submarine but they they call it an iron
whale they don't get it he came in an
iron whale from Beneath the Sea he
figures it out by the zippers because I
look all this stuff up zippers were not
invented until after 1738. it's obvious
they are from the future instead of
buttons they fasten their trousers with
interlocking metal teeth
so that the guy from the 1960s submarine
cap you think we were from the future
because our pants have zippers so that
kind of stuff so it's not that we have a
nuclear submarine yeah but when they
meet they eat meet the Pirates they
assume they're hippies on dope
pretending to be Pirates you know they
hippies on dope
what I love is um when you were first
messing around with this for just for
fun yeah I think the best things come
out of uh just joy and fun you were
doing these just for fun with your with
your sons and you were sending them to
me yeah a little little segments yeah
and I would be I don't know I'd be
driving around somewhere I'd be doing
something I'd be making a a smoothie and
then Bing and I'd look down and you
would send me a new short 10-minute
episode of the weird place that you guys
had just made for fun and I would listen
to it and just have a blast uh that's
the whole idea and the the the joy of it
and the positivity of it uh you know I I
I feel like if anybody's laying around
in their room or driving their car or
going to the gym this is something that
I'm hoping that they'll listen to more
than once because it's every moment is
thought out very very carefully every
single second of it we want to be
satisfying and it is one of those things
for me to get clarity like if I had 12
billion dollars I would be doing the
weird place I know it's the most
satisfying creative thing I think I've
ever done wow it's fantastic yeah
because I I'm able to put empathy and
Pathos in it at given moments not too
heavy-handed right but I want it to have
an innocence to it and this is pre-ted
lasso you know yeah I felt starved for
the old Twilight Zone starved for it and
my sons as well so we're just we just
love it just love doing it it's very
hard work I have to say well it shows
it's it's uh it's a joy to listen to uh
the weird place is out now listen
wherever you get your podcast Dana
Carvey thank thank you thank you